hey friends how's it going welcome back
to deep dive what you're about to hear
is an interview with will store who is
the best-selling author of this book the
status game and he's written a bunch of
other books including a book selfie
which is all about like selfie and
social media culture and how we're
obsessed with ourselves but this new one
is fantastic it's called the status game
and it's one of my favorite topics it's
basically about all of the different
ways in which practically all human
behavior is ultimately motivated towards
seeking and acquiring more social status
we talk about how status is a
fundamental part of the human condition
and how this has been a thing from like
the dawn of time we talk a little bit
about the three different types of
status games that we can play in
everything that we do and we talk a
little bit about how the pursuit of
status is often seen as a negative thing
but it can actually drive us to do
bigger and better things with our lives
and we also talk about practical ways to
increase one's social status if you're
into that kind of thing by you know
tactics like warmth and sincerity which
sound like tactics but are actually just
generally being a decent human being so
yeah hope you enjoy the discussion that
okay let's talk about let's talk about
the status game how did you come become
interested in the topic of the pursuit
of social status well so the heretics
and then selfie and then the science of
storytelling those three books were all
about that idea of the brain as a
storyteller they were all pursuing this
one idea which is the brain is
is this delusional machine which as i
said before remix this reality into this
heroic story we're in the middle of the
world the universe everything revolves
around us we're amazing you know as long
as we're psychologically healthy we have
all these you know creative artists so
i you know i started to think okay so if
that's um
if that's what's really going on if
that's the kind of delusion we're in the
middle of if that's the kind of lie of
the brain what's the truth of the brain
what's actually going on kind of beneath
the hood and um so so this phrase that i
read um i think it was a psychological i
think robert hogan came up with this
phrase that i i used in the selfie and
the science of storytelling that that
our you know our secret subconscious
drive is to get along and get ahead and
i thought that i always loved that
because it's it feels it's so simple to
understand
and the reason it's those things is
because we're tribal we're a tribal
animal we you know we're these apes that
have mastered the art of um cooperative
living um uh you know we we we we we're
driven to and and so so for those
reasons we have these very strong
subconscious urges to getting together
in groups of people who
are like-minded
and um you know pursue goals with them
um but also
compete for status
with other members of that group but
also those groups compete for status
with rival groups and so that's tribal
life that's life in the tribe you know
um
that's why we organized the human life
is organized like that because it was
organized like that 20 000 years ago on
the african savannah
and you know i always find it's amazing
that's still human life today you know
those groups are political groups
they're football teams their um you know
cults their religions their corporations
that we
this is what we do that's human social
life it's groupish and it's complete
competition
and and so so the status game is is
really a book about that get along and
get ahead you know that's what it gave
me as a game is you get along you you
clump into a gay of group that you're
playing a game with and then you you
start competing yeah how did the story
kind of come together did you start off
with the hypothesis that this is a thing
and then find the stories and the
examples and stuff to back it up or wait
was it more investigative like what was
the approach there yeah
it was
so when i was researching selfie and
selfie is about um how the west west in
the west were very individualistic and
you know self-obsessed
um relatively speaking to the rest of
the world and and so it was looking kind
of selfie culture that narcissistic
selfie culture was a great title by the
way yeah it wasn't my i can't take
credit yeah i remember seeing it like i
think in 2017 or something yeah this one
came out
yeah oh that's an interesting book yeah
good yeah um yeah and um and i i
interviewed this guy called professor
bruce hurd who's a very well-known
psychologist down at the university of
bristol
and his put in my interview he said to
me oh you know he said why do we do the
things that we do so once we've got
enough money to
live and survive and we've got enough
money for our families to survive
everything is just about validation you
didn't use the word status you use the
word validation you know that's why we
write books that's why we pursue that's
why i'm a scientist and yeah
and when he said that my immediate
response was oh come on that's so
cynical that's a ridiculous thing to say
and then i just sort of thought about it
for another like 30 seconds and i just
thought i think he's right i think he's
right i really do think he's right and
that that just really stayed with me and
then i just started researching it so
i'd really re
doing looking at the science of kind of
status but then
what the light bulb moment for me was
really
the game part of it but because if you
just say it's all about status that's
half the story the other half is the
connection you know once you once we've
connected it's like connecting with
other people so so once they've started
to realize that um
that um
[Music]
one of the light bulb moments for me was
was one of my ghost writing clients
actually
i need a guy with a working class
background he became very successful
and he's very very alpha male
like you know powerful
um uh you know
military background like for some middle
class lower middle class like book geek
like me quite intimidating and um you
know when i first met him it was a
meeting at a publishing company
i was a bit nervous to be with him
because i felt like
as far as he's concerned i'm this wimp
this little nerdy wimp you know with my
little cardigan on but i kind of felt he
was a bit nervous to meet me he was a
bit uncomfortable meeting me and that
really made me so i was
what was going on there and it was great
because he was really nice and i was
expecting him to be a bit
dismissive of me but it was so nice you
know and he was really enthusiastic to
understand and his whole thing with me
was just like mate i don't know what you
do but just do what you do yeah just
make this a great book and you know he
really trusted me yeah and um
and then and that was the big
breakthrough for me because because i
could because i realized that we have
different ways of measuring status
like his way of measuring status is with
physical strength banter
probably football like talking about
football
that's his criteria for claiming status
and that that's what he's proud of you
know his physicality yeah
whereas my criteria for claiming status
are things like books you've written and
getting nice reviews in the times or
you
know
[ __ ] paintings on the walls all those
kinds of things and um
and
that's when i suddenly realized it's
we're not all competing with each other
we're playing different status games so
so when he came around my house to work
on my book and he saw the paintings on
the walls and all the books on the
shelves
even with the fact of his incredibly
masculine life
he probably would have felt a little bit
intimidated and a little bit
uncomfortable because he's in he's in a
different world now yeah and his
criteria for claiming status suddenly
doesn't count yeah and he you know um
and when i go into his world and and i'm
meeting with his very very masculine
terrifying you know people i'm like yeah
it's you know i mean everyone's really
nice so
you know but but but that was the
breakthrough like we're playing
different status games and the thing to
understand is that is that we're not all
competing with each other we're all
playing little individual games and each
of these games has kind of symbolic
um ways of claiming status so you think
about monopoly the way you the way you
symbolize stages in monopoly is those
little plastic houses and hotels and the
money um and and that's how we play
status again so his symbolic
um
claims to status is his physicality his
history of extreme violence
um you know his success he's huge
successes in that physical world yeah um
and probably he's very proud of playing
i don't know if you can imagine football
or whatever those things are
and mine are completely different um but
and it was
and it was that understanding that
really
made me see the world in a different way
to understand
the status games that we all play and
how
how they drive us and make us kind of
different kinds of people we're going to
take a very quick break to introduce our
sponsor brilliant brilliant is a
fantastic online platform for learning
maths science and computer science with
interactive and engaging courses that
i've been using for many years but to be
honest i wish i'd had their lessons in
maths to hand when i was preparing for
my bmat when applying to medical school
a lot of the time when we're taught
maths at school the focus is on empty
memorization of formulas that we can
apply in our exams but the great thing
about brilliant is their courses teach
you how to actually understand concepts
from a first principles approach and
develop the intuition to solve problems
also their computer science series is
absolutely sick they've got some
fantastic courses on algorithms on
learning to program with python they've
got a whole series about cryptocurrency
and understanding exactly how things
like bitcoin work from the ground up
which is genuinely fascinating so if you
want to give their lessons and maths a
try or even science or computer science
then head over to brilliant.org forward
slash deep dive and the first 200 people
to sign up by that link will get 20 off
the annual subscription to the website
so thank you so much brilliant for
sponsoring this episode yeah
yeah as i was listening to the audiobook
i found myself thinking that it is very
hard to get away from the fact from the
idea that
seeking status is bad
and that you know
similar to with the the stuff they talk
about in in the elephant in the brain
you know that that quote from allegedly
from jp morgan that a man always has two
reasons for doing something the good
reason and the real reason and if i
think of like what's my real reason for
being a youtuber for doing this podcast
for one of wanting to write a book it's
like if i've got to be honest with
myself it is broadly status motivated
and i'm like [ __ ]
this is bad like shouldn't i have a more
like altruistic impact and it's like
yeah it's kind of nice like teaching
people it's kind of fun talking to a
camera but but really
if i was doing it
if i was like talking to people and then
hitting delete rather than hitting
publish suddenly that changes the
equation and so okay what's going on
there um yeah but what do you think
about that that like when when i guess
when we think or when we point out the
status thing it feels like a negative it
does feel like a negative and that was
the journey i went on because it isn't i
mean it can be a negative there's lots
of negative in the book about about the
bad sides of the status game but it's
also what's made civilization it's what
is what makes us good people
you know the history of the status game
again goes back to those tribes the
tribes in which we evolved and so you
know nature has to find a way of
incentivizing us to be valuable people
you know we
humans
can be very selfish and self-interested
and delusional and you know all those
things so how do you get
these creatures that have a tendency
towards selfishness to be selfless and
to work for the benefit of the tribe
where you incentivize them with status
and status is this reward so so what
happened was um you know we were playing
status games with our reputation we had
a reputation and try was you know um and
you'd get a good reputation you'd go up
in the status game if you proved
yourself to be valuable to the tribe and
there's two ways of being valuable to
the tribe you can be virtuous so you can
be generous courageous in battle a
follower of rules and an enforcer of
rules or you can be successful so um you
can be valuable to try by being a really
great honey finder a really great hunter
a really great storyteller a really
great sorcerer and so so so so it's this
reward that you get for being valuable
for being useful for being kind and
generous
and and so so that was true ten thousand
years ago is to still true today it's if
you think about like we're not used to
uh seeing people like gandhi and um
you know um malala as
superstars as celebrities but they are
you know that they are moral superstars
and that's good it's good that's that's
good that that's humanity at its best i
think is when we see valuable people
like like gandhi or like um
the people who invented the astrazeneca
vaccine that you know um and we make
celebrities of them we're celebrating
the movies we're making them heroic and
so you know without that we wouldn't
have civilization we wouldn't have the
moral world as we know it because you
know you can feel it
with with the moral status thing when
you do something good and kind you feel
it in your body you go
you feel up you literally feel
physically up you know and when other
people find out they've done a nice
thing they go oh that's amazing yeah and
they and that's an automatic
response
and that's brilliant it's that's the
best of the human animal so so i do
think it's i i completely agree with you
that we are used to our condition to
seeing status is this negative thing and
it can be a very negative thing but it's
also the very very best of who we are as
a as a species
you know
in the book i talk about like things
like the origin of the iphone for
example
you know you know when steve jobs um
uh kept meeting this guy from microsoft
at these parties because his wife was
friends with his wife
and this guy would be well we've solved
computing we're going to kill apple
we've got this new touchscreen device
with a stylus yeah and um steve jobs was
just livid because he was like hey you
know he didn't talk to me like that this
microsoft solved computing and he came
in and apparently there was a set of
expletives and he said right we're going
to show them how it's really done and
it's not a stylus it's your finger make
the thing with the finger and they made
it and that was the iphone and then
again the ipad it started obviously yeah
so so you know that's a a great example
of
somebody very steve jobs very interested
in status unusually you know obsessed
with status
um and you know the iphone for good for
better or worse has changed the world uh
and and it began with
just somebody feeling belittled a
barbecue in in california i guess if if
we think of our own our own motivations
kind of on on an individual level
the way the way i the way i kind of
think of it is that
there is always some kind of status game
that i'm that i'm playing in basically
everything i do but there's nothing i
can do about it and so it's actually
kind of fine and so similar to you know
why why do i go to the gym well i can
pretend it's for health reasons but but
really everyone knows
what the real reason behind going to the
gym is yeah but that's that's it's not
the end of the world it's you know we
don't need to have fully pure altruistic
motives for the things we do to still
actually be good that's right it's like
men's health isn't really a health
magazine it's a sexy body magazine it's
an i want to look good naked magazine
you know and that's yeah that that's
right and and um
yeah
um i think the health version of that
wouldn't i don't think it would
celebrate
um
um yeah you can't you can't um
get away from it um it's it's in your
kind of body it's in your brain you know
as soon as you're out um
in the world mixing with people
it's automatic you're judging them
they're judging you
the game is on you know
so
one thing that i think they talk about
in the book is
when status is taken away that can often
be like a really really terrible thing i
wonder if you can kind of elaborate that
on
on that a little bit yeah um
so
status is this kind of social nutrient
it's like it's an essential kind of
thing that we need we need to feel
respected and valued by the people
around us and when we don't we become
unwell um we become psychologically
unwell um you know become depressed
become stressed become anxious
um uh
we also can become physically unwell
when we're kind of repeatedly um uh you
know robbed of status um
at its most extreme um you know in the
book i write about humiliation the state
of humiliation
and humiliation is
we've all been there it's a horrific
kind of experience and humiliation is
this
it's not just that you've been robbed of
all your status within a group you've
been robbed of the ability to claim it
ever again in the future like you're so
it's been it's gone so wrong yeah that
people are like leave we don't have
anything to do with you anymore and
you're kind of forbidden from the group
and that's i mean you know that that's a
fearsome thing
subconsciously that that that's that's
the equivalent you know in the back in
the tribal days
if if we were if
if we were if we were that lacking in
states within the group it would have
been probably a death sentence either
we're kicked out of the group and that's
a death center in itself or we were
executed execution capital punishment is
thought to have once been a human
universal
um so um
so we really fear it and you know we
need to say we need status it's it's
this kind of fundamental
you know psychological nutrients
and and i think when in the book i write
about people who have been who are kind
of humiliated again and again and again
and again and and these are the people
that become very unwell and often
extremely violent you know there's a
chapter in the book on
mass murderers you know serial killers
spread killers terrorists honor killers
um
and um
humiliation is deeply implicated in all
of those you know phenomena
given that
kind of if we if we accept that we're
all sort of playing status games
is there
is there anything that
we
can should do differently as we're going
about our lives in keeping keeping that
on the back of our minds yeah i i think
i i think it's useful to be aware of the
the game is you know when the game is in
in process
it's often very easy to become irritated
and frustrated by little slights that
people might make to us
um and
you know anybody who's seen kirby
enthusiasm that's all about a guy who is
highly attuned to kind of status lights
in in the book i write about this study
where
about orange glasses of orange juice and
this is the thing if you pile you if you
pour lots of glasses of orange juice for
people but you get slightly less orange
juice than everybody else it's really
like you get really upset about it you
know and and that's because it's not
it's not actually just a mouthful of
orange juice you've been robbed of yeah
it's it's
your brain has gone it's gone that's
symbolic of your status so that's how
insanely obsessed the brain is as i've
gone just brain is with our our relative
status and we're all used to you know
every day we have an experience where we
feel a bit slighted and i think once you
understand that that's just your brain
being a completely obsessive idiot about
your status it's much easier to you
don't stop feeling the feeling yeah but
you can i think you can separate
yourself from them much easier and just
stop almost like a buddhist look upon
yourself and go oh that's my brain being
stupid um but but i think one of the big
takeaways as well as is that is that i
think we often forget that um
you know we have status to give like the
prestige forms of status virtue and
success those two forms of prestige
um we get them from other people other
people voluntarily give them to us when
we do good things
and um so we have status to give
unlimited reserves of status to give
other people and we're often quite bad
at giving it we often quite jealously
kind of jealously hoard
our kind of stores of status and i think
no
i think just life for ourselves
it gets much better when we're more
generous with status yeah you know even
for a selfish reason that people want to
be around us more if we're giving out if
we're giving out that stuff as long as
you're not um completely unauthentic
about it i think there's a risk that you
go it's like hollywood and you know like
the la thing oh my god you look amazing
yeah and nobody believes the word you're
saying you know as long as it doesn't
sort of lapse into that i i think
understanding that great gift that you
have yeah and that you can give it to
people and really make their day so what
does that look like in practice
like is it like laughing at someone's
joke even if it's borderline funny and
or whatever i don't think i don't think
it's being i don't think you have to be
inauthentic about it yeah i i think i
think there's always something nice you
can find to say about somebody
and um
yeah and it's just saying it yeah you
know like sometimes you can go wrong i
was just like the reason i stopped there
was because i was slightly uncomfortable
um i was doing an interview to promote
the status game with this woman and um
on the radio she had a really beautiful
speaking voice and after the um
after the interview i said you've got
such a beautiful speaking voice and i
think i made her a bit uncomfortable i
think she thought i was coming on to her
oh god
you've got to be careful about that i
really wasn't you know but like i was
just trying to be nice yeah but it's
things like that you know there's always
something nice something nice i mean i
might she might not i was worried that
she thought that it came it came out
badly
um but um but yes it's as long as um
as long as it doesn't come off as creepy
or sincere
you know i i think that there's always
this sort of gift that we can give other
people
yeah
that makes a lot of sense um you said in
another podcast that you were on i think
on jordan hobbing the show
you said um
that
the whole you were talking about this
whole idea of when people say oh i don't
care what people think of me yeah i
wonder if we can like elaborate on that
a little bit what's the deal with that
we are going to take a little quick
break from the podcast to introduce the
sponsor of this podcast which is
curiosity stream if you haven't heard by
now curiosity streams is the world's
leading documentary streaming
subscription platform founded by john
hendricks who's the founder of the
discovery channel and on curiosity
stream they've got hundreds of really
high quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of the
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is a service called nebula which
you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available on
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiositystream loves supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity streams
incredible library of documentaries and
also free access to all of the stuff on
nebula bundled with that so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive to get the bundle deal so thank you
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episode well it's not true it's never
true you know we're a social animal we
we are wired you know to our core to
care about what other people think of us
it's in the human machine it's part of
our human nature to care about what
other people think of us and i think as
i said before it always makes me laugh
when people say that because they always
say in a certain way i don't care what
people think of me yeah and they're like
you're just sure you know that's just
another way of claiming status you're
claiming that you're better than
everybody else yeah like you know
and it's so ironic because it's
obviously very important to them that
other people think
that they don't care what other people
think about them so it's just you know
it's just it's just it's just never true
and i think if it is true
um if it ever was true about somebody
that that that's going to be a person
who is extremely badly socially adjusted
and will
likely end up either in prison or in a
sort of
institution you know
if you
you're not going to be a functional
person yeah
so
there was an interesting chapter we
talked about sort of the uh
the sort of the
the real life cues that we give off when
we are higher status or lower status
and i wonder like often you know we did
a survey for the podcast and people said
that they like getting actionable tips
that they can apply in their work life
yeah i was kind of thinking that like
are there actionable tips that you can
apply in your work life for example
knowing knowing that the status game
exists
in every every relationship you're going
to have at work for example yeah i think
i i think so you know what one of the
things i think is really important is is
in in the business context is to always
have that understanding that you're
you're never the hero in other people's
stories they're always the hero they're
always the one on this great pursuit of
status which their brain remixes as this
kind of heroic you know pursuit
and so it's much better in a business
context to come across as um the kind of
that like you're a helpful person in
their story yeah so there's a story
scholar who i think is really smart guy
called christopher booker who wrote a
book called the seven basic plots it's
like a huge like 2 000 word
2000 page thing i think it's like a huge
um
kind of tome but but he he writes about
um this archetypal figure in story
called the light figure and and the
exhaust and the light figure is like um
the light doesn't light yeah exactly the
light figure and the light figures come
into the story and they're like the
ghost in the christmas carol yeah their
job is there to help scrooge become
heroic to see the area of idea and so i
think in the business context if you go
in there boast boasting i'm amazing you
want to work with me i'm fantastic
you're going to put people off because
you're not the hero they're the hero
yeah so you're much better off being the
light figure and your story is this is
how i'm going to help you gain status
i'm going to do these things to help you
and so that's the first thing and then
the second thing is
is about impression management
so um you know there's lots of sciences
looked at looked at how do we how
socially do we give a good impression to
other to other people
and
for a long time
they
talked about two domains warmth and
competence
and more recently it's been argued that
there's a there should be a third domain
out of that which is morality
and when i was reading about this it
really struck me because in the book i
write about those three status games as
dominance which is the aggressive
animalistic status game there's virtue
and their success and those three they
called them warmth competence and
morality but i i called it warmth
confidence and sincerity okay you map on
perfectly to those three status games
yeah so i don't i don't know but i don't
think that's a coincidence you know i i
i think that that that that it's
interesting that those map onto those um
three stages games so well and the logic
is when you approach somebody with
warmth what you're subconsciously
signaling to that person is that i'm not
going to um compete for status with
dominance with you i'm not going to
threaten you i'm not going to coerce you
i'm not going to
use physical violence against you you
know so we're going to have a healthy
um
non-aggressive status game when you're
signaling with sincerity
you're saying i'm going to play a good
virtue game with you which is i'm going
to be um you know morally respectable it
does not mean i'm going to suck up to
you i'm not going to give you [ __ ]
i'm going to tell you the truth and when
i'm not happy i'm going to tell you i'm
not happy so i'm going to be sincere you
know always going to be honest with you
and then finally competence if you if
you come across as a competent person
you are
you are signaling not only am i going to
be useful to our
not only am i going to be useful to our
our our group our game but you know you
also might learn some stuff from me so
there are there are things that i can do
and if you learn how to do them from me
you're also going to raise in status
yeah so i think if you if you can it's
obviously easier said than done but but
if you can if you can manifest in those
three ways warmth sincerity and
competence yeah it's very hard to know
how you're going to fail in life
you know and you know you can't just
come across in those ways you've got to
actually live those ideals you've got to
be sincere you've got to be
non-aggressive yeah and you've got to be
competent you've got to be good at your
you know you've got to be good at the
thing that you're doing so so yeah that
that i think though is that that's kind
of a practical nice um um idea sincerity
and confidence competence oh competence
yeah confidence yeah it trusts me uh
have you seen suits
no oh so there's this uh it's this uh
lawyer show and this is guy harvey
specter um he's like this big shot
lawyer and the way he comes across to
his clients is very warm sincere and and
competent okay well he comes across to
his uh his opposition is very like
dominant like yes full-on alpha male
like that kind of stuff going on yeah do
you think in
non-work context like in social contexts
the it strikes me that maybe the
competence matters less and it's
actually about warmth and sincerity yeah
i think you know there is always those
two things going on connection and
status getting along and getting ahead
yeah and i think when it comes to
connection belongingness warmth and
sincerity are obviously really important
yeah and yeah i i was thinking
connection more important i mean
you know um you know um yeah virtue i
guess matters for for status and for
connection yeah but but but i think yes
but status um but um competence is is
very much a kind of status
yeah yeah you me you're attracted to
composite people because you're
impressed by them not because you feel
like you want to yeah yeah yeah yeah i
remember i was i was reading happy by
darren brown
um
he talks about stoicism and stuff um and
one of the lines that really
stuck with me and from that book was
that
we think people are attracted or people
we we we sometimes think people are
attracted to competence but in fact
they're attracted to warmth and like
i i think definitely when i was younger
i thought the way to make friends was to
signal how competent i was at like a b
and c and then over time i actually
realized that actually no no one
actually cares in a friend's context
yeah in a business networking type
context fine but in a friend's context
actually warmth and sincerity
yeah i think i think that's true and
yeah i think that's true but but i also
think there's a
i don't think i i think you could like
at school people who want to be friends
with the best footballer you know so
yeah there's that element yeah i do
there is that stuff going on as well i
don't think it's true to say completely
like that that we're not we don't want
to be friends with competent people
because i don't i don't you know people
people who are really able are very
attractive people like they they suck in
people around them
there's a there's a book called the
secret of our success by joseph henrich
which is really good writing about that
about how
attractive competence is to to up to
other people and and you know i wonder
if there's a gender difference there too
i i don't know whether it's more of a
kind of male thing i don't know oh on on
that note in your research did you
notice any gender differences in how the
different genders compete for status
the the i i try to keep away from gender
a little bit because it's so dangerous
it's a dangerous area to derive that
yeah but so i kept i i kept it on not
quite safe ground but safe in terms of
the of the research yeah and and so
so the research on this is so solid it's
basically inarguable yeah like it's so
well evidenced and so so all over the
world um
there is a generalized and this
important says general it's not every
woman is different from every man in
this way it's just a generalization but
generally speaking um there are
difference in interests in the kind of
games that we play
so women tend to be more interested in
people and men tend to be more
interested in interested in things so if
you got 100
you know people 50 women 50 men together
and said step forward those who are
interested in tractors the chances are
that more men than women would step
forward and you know what that means is
that if you in a tractor if you've got a
tractor factory there's going to be more
men than women working there and more
men at the top of the hierarchy and
that's not going to be because of sexism
it's because of predictable differences
in interest so so i thought
so that's that that's as far as i went
with with gender in the book because
it's so well evidenced that like it's
it's so clear that difference and it's
so universal the question is whether
that's um
genetic whether it's actually in our
genes or or whether it's socialization
but because it's universal i'm i'm
dubious that it's completely
socialization like if it was
socialization cultures are so different
around the world you'd expect to look
like a lot of variety you'd expect to
find this culture over here where it
where where the where you know the
computer engineers are mostly women and
you know you know that doesn't exist
yeah you know so so so you know there
was there were yes so that is very well
evidence that so and and and i think
that's that that's a mistake that's
often made in the culture where you get
certain industries that are male
dominated and somewhat they're female
like you know teaching nursing female
dominated and and and that there's often
a kind of patriarchy argument like an
argument from conspiracy
uh overlaid on top of that um and often
that's not really what's going on it's
just it's just a result of how generally
speaking
um the injustice in that for me is that
often those that those people centered
industries they don't pay
well compared to the things versus
industries and that's not that's the
thing that's not fair yeah yeah but how
you fixed that
who knows yeah yeah well while we're on
the topic did you did you come across
any race differences in how the status
game is played at all not race
differences no no no i'd be very
skeptical if somebody's argued that
there are any race differences i think
there are cultural differences
yeah yeah so there are big cultural
differences the the the the main one
that
we know about academically is east
versus west so west we're individualist
and so we see status pursue more is much
more about the individual um it's you
know about me and my achievements and so
it's so you know we're kind of self
aggrandizing
um um uh you know we're kind of
relatively show-offy whereas in the east
that's seen as very taboo and the east
is much more communitarian countries
confucian versus aristotle in a way and
that confucian communitarian culture is
much more about the group and so so the
so status is much more about the group
serving the group and so how that
how that manifests in in day-to-day life
there was a very interesting paper that
i write about in the book um by i think
it was a japanese anthropologist who
writes about face the concept of faith
and um and he said it's fascinating he
said that um
that
in japan if an individual is picked out
one member of a group is picked out of
individual praise
that seems extremely shameful
and embarrassing because because what
you've done is you've made everybody
else look worse in the group and so what
they'll do that person usually is
they'll deliberately do a really
terrible job at work you know for the
next days or weeks in order to be the
worst in the group to kind of re
rebalance the group you know so that's
completely the opposite in the west
where it's like i'm the best [ __ ] you
guys yeah you know that that's kind of
the war the thing that we do so so
that's a huge cultural difference and in
you know i wrote about that in selfie
susan kane also writes about this in her
book quiet and in the book she writes
about how in in china shyness is seen as
a leadership quality which again is a
completely different way
that we experience the status game in
the west it's much more about confidence
personal confidence here but you know
whereas people with shyness are high
status in china so so definitely so so
no race differences but but certainly
lots and lots of cultural differences
um
the whole status thing has completely
been around for a very long time
um but then you add the internet and you
add social media onto this thing um what
are the kind of implications
in your
well social media is just one huge
status game if you think about those
three those three games um dominance
virtue and success yeah um that's what
social media is it's like people there's
people doing dominance
you know being aggressive to each other
yeah you know bullying each other doxing
and cancelling and all that stuff um
there's virtue people signaling oh i
think this is the talk about politics is
all about virtue stuff this is this
person's bad this person's good this law
is bad this law is good
you know all that stuff um and there's
also success games look at my amazing
gym body look at my healthy breakfast
look at my tan knees in the maldives you
know so so that and that that that's
what's that's what social media is it's
dominance virtue and success and and so
you know one of the things i also write
about in selfies this is this idea we
have that you know these are kind of
inventions of silicon valley and they've
kind of created these things which have
like distorted the world and made us but
i think i don't think that's how it
works um
you know in selfie i write about how the
selfie camera was invented as a business
tool
for doing you know conferences and um it
was called the front-facing camera when
it was launched and then it was us the
people that decided to do selfies and
then the tech companies went okay that's
what you want to do with them then his
instagram and his you know his you know
yes
you know twitter wasn't twitter as we
know when it launched it was a free sms
text message service you know so so so
what you've got these technologies kind
of working out by trial and instinct
what people want and giving it to them
and what people want are status games
and that's what twitter is that's what
instagram is that's what tick toc is um
and in the book you know i write about
and i call that
the social media is slot machine for the
status and i think it's quite well known
um by people who are interested in in
sort of back have kind of behind the
scenes interest in social media all that
the bj fought behavior model which is
that idea is this kind of evil genius
who um he wrote this book in 2003
predicting the iphone just extraordinary
you know writing about this young girl
who has this device that's about the
size of a pack of cards and a whole
life's on it and maybe like he basically
foresaw the thing in 2003 it was
unbelievable uh not only did he foresee
the iphone or the smartphone um he
um
he he he he he's like this model of how
to make it basically
not addictive like a compulsive like to
me to make it so it was hard to put down
and um
and what he wrote was that what you want
to make is it's you know it gives
rewards and but the rewards are
um uh are unpredictable yeah so like a
slot machine you pull you don't know
what's gonna happen you're gonna get the
money you're not gonna get the money and
so when it's unpredictable you can't
stop looking at it and and so that's
quite well known but but i think the
missing piece for me is that is what are
you gambling with and what you're
gambling with is status that's exactly
what you're gambling with whenever you
make a contribution to social media yeah
whether it's a
comment on twitter or a photo on
instagram or whatever or something on
linkedin about your new project yeah you
always want to refresh and be like how
many likes have i got exactly it's like
how's it done how's it done and you can
go up you can go down you know and
that's what's compulsive about it so so
yeah that that's that that and i think
that's why social media is universally
like it's gone around the world it's not
just a western thing it's all around the
world um and because
it's status status is a universally
necessary it's part of the human
condition it's part of the it's part of
what we are as a as a species so it's
it's addictive
yeah yeah i guess one of the
one of the main takeaways that i took
because i'm as as i read stuff like this
i'm always kind of interested like yeah
that's cool kind of from a society level
in terms of understanding stuff but is
there something that i can do myself to
kind of apply this knowledge in an
interesting way yeah and
i i often think about status when it
comes to um
when it when it comes to how i feel
about like my own career and stuff where
like back back in the day where my
my peer group was medical students and
doctors there was a status game going on
for who was getting the highest grades
who was the best looking who was the
best at sports et cetera like there were
all these different kind of fields of
status game being being played but
because i was doing the the the youtube
stuff and business stuff at university
i'd sort of opted out of the
the status games that quote everyone
else was playing and was doing very well
in this other thing which to me what and
what i was like oh yeah i'm high status
because i'm the only one who's doing
this doing this business stuff
um and then over time as you know as i
was working for two years as a doctor i
was one of the probably most successful
youtubers in that sphere very easy to
win that status game
now that i am not a doctor anymore i'm
like [ __ ] like now the status game that
i sort of find myself playing is with
all of the other youtubers yeah of which
there are loads of them who are more
successful than i am
and so i find myself doing this weird
thing where
or for example where like i speak to a
lot of startup founders and startup
founders make like stupid amounts of
money even more stupid amounts than
youtubers make yes yes
you know like you know having having two
million subscribers is cool this guy's
got 100 million pound business
um and because the the peer group the
comparison group has changed the way
that i personally feel about my own
accomplishments and my own level of
status is always kind of in flux based
on who i'm speaking to and all this kind
of stuff
uh but when i recognize this i kind of
take a step back try to do that kind of
buddhist thing of like no hang on this
is just my brain going wild because of
the status stuff i actually don't need
to think this way i can actually just
try and focus on being grateful for what
i have and trying to opt out of the
status game as much as possible knowing
that it's never really going to be fully
possible because we're all human at the
end of the day but it is at least
something to aspire to i think
yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah it's um
it's uh yeah it's uh
i think it's really valuable to
understand
the game that we're all playing and then
once you do you can
yeah you could you you can kind of think
yourself you can sort of foster more
kind of healthy habits i thought i think
in in that way and yeah it's tough i
mean you know the game that you're
playing now as a youtuber is hard you
know it's a tough one and and and but as
i said before i i think the trick is is
knowing this isn't
the last game you're going to be playing
if this is going to stop exactly yeah
it's a stepping stone so who's what yeah
exactly yeah yeah
nice um i i posted it on instagram
asking if anyone has uh questions for
you and so we have a bunch of
a bunch of questions that people have
asked through through twitter and
through instagram so
sarah kowi asks
how does status actually lead to
longevity if it doesn't lead to
happiness
she's getting some kind of link between
status and longevity well there's a
famous set of studies called the white
horse studies
um there's a guy called dr michael
marmot which looked at um
the civils the british civil service
which huge huge organization very
stratified
and what he found was that
the higher you add up the hierarchy the
better your health outcomes and the
lower your mortality um and
you know and so
you might think okay that's because the
the richer you are the more you're
eating salad and having a personal
trainer um but that wasn't true it was
separate from from kind of lifestyle and
all that stuff and
what he found was that that you know if
the person at the very top of that
hierarchy smoked and the person one
beneath that person also smoked that one
person believed to be more likely to get
sick as a result of their smoking than
the one at the top
so
so it was incredibly the brain is
incredibly um
um
sensitive to to our level of relative
states where we sit in our status games
of life um and they found that this is
true for men and for women um
and their health differentials were
really quite um uh extraordinary um
that they even found it in laboratory
conditions with baboons so so they call
these baboons these poor bloody baboons
in a lab and they fed them a really
terrible diet like you know high-calorie
crisps or whatever yeah what it was
pretty delicious
you know really bad for them yeah um and
and they found that the same thing was
the food was for true for baboons as was
in civil service was that the lower you
were in the hierarchy the more likely
they were to get sick as a result of
their bad diets and then they changed
the hierarchy they i don't know how they
did it but they conspired to change the
hierarchy of the baboon troop and the
health outcomes changed in lockstep so
so that's just extraordinary evidence
that the marmot course is the status
syndrome that the and so you know it's
kind of speculative
as to why that's true but there's a
field called social genomics quite a new
field called social genomics and social
genomics is the science of how our
social worlds impact the function of our
genes
and interviewed a guy called professor
steve cole out in university of
california who's an expert in social
genomics and in in he he thinks it's to
do with
um inflammation um which obviously
you'll know all about as a medic
the idea that
if we're kind of lower and lower on the
totem pole
the body's preparing you for attack and
for trouble and for crisis and we're not
designed to be an information for a long
period of time and we've done it's been
information for a short bit of time and
if we and and it also changes our
antiviral response
um so so so that's that's what he thinks
is that's what they think is going on so
so so i wouldn't say so
i guess it wouldn't quite be true to say
that having high status gets you
longevity it's probably more accurate to
say that having started at the higher
stage protects you from getting here
it's kind of the same thing yeah but
it's probably slightly more accurate to
say it's not like yeah it's not like a
long line it kind of is a long life
though but it is like a it's more like a
protective thing against against illness
yeah yeah good stuff um we have a
question from yeah jamie donnell i guess
we've sort of covered this um does
everyone see status in the same way i
might not see something as high status
that another person does
yeah no they don't they don't no so so a
classic example would be um cars
you know if you're if you're a
middle-class person
um driving a shiny hound or a shiny bmw
or you know like a whatever um it's seen
as a high status thing but if you're
above that in the social class system
and aristotle that's seen as a low
status thing and and and what and you
know why i live in the country the the
the proper poshes they drive around a
knack at old
um you know land rover covered in
dog hair and mud and and they'll
actively look down and it's the same as
you know like you might get somebody who
is in the wellness world for example um
who drives a battered old car and but
that's their status symbol they're
showing the game that aren't that
they're they're using you know they're
they're they're you know it's a no we
all play different status games and we
all have different criteria for claiming
status and you know yeah
i grew up with a not grub when i've told
when i was working in the record shop i
lived with a modern white really kind of
i was a lodger and and another guy
living in the house was tim
he was a hippie and he was in a very
source is very anti-materialistic
and in his head he wasn't playing the
status game because he didn't care about
positions and all that stuff but of
course he was it's just that's that's
his way of that's his criteria for
claiming status looking down his nose at
people who wanted to buy a big telly
his small telly was his statistical
um nice so we've got a question from
king to underscore cool who says how are
children attracted to status as they
grow up ah that's a great question um
well um
it's almost immediate and so i mentioned
bruce hill earlier who was the guy that
got me thinking about this in the first
place and he's published a very
interesting book called possession which
is about the psychology of possessions
and he writes about um kids who
fight over toys and so so you know um
toys as a status symbol the reason they
want the toy um is is not because they
want the toy it's because who has the
toys on top so so that's that's how
that's the kind of one example very
early manifestation of the status gaming
kids
and so and so you know during childhood
those are the kinds of basic games we're
playing and you know we're demanding
states we're crying and you know getting
upset when we don't get the toy and and
then what happens in
early adolescence
is our brains begin to change in a very
specific way and and and they change
such that we become much more interested
in social status in the sense of what
our peer groups think of us is much is
much less about what we've got i want i
want i want it's much more about what
other people think about me and so
that's why
you know teenagers are this really weird
combination of like risk takers that
drive too fast and historically they
would smoke and drink but i think the
current generation quite so much we did
you know risk takers but they're also
really like self-conscious and get
really embarrassed as because they're
highly highly attuned to status so the
risk-taking is all about look at me and
this and the high self-consciousness is
all about is is just that huge sudden
awareness that you're being judged by
everybody that's looking at you and
that's because the brain is suddenly
changed and it's making you it's kind of
making you an adult you know
you you'll be you're playing adult
status games yeah and that's why peer
group is so important you know why
that's why parents have this they have
this experience of losing their children
adolescents they become other people and
the peer group becomes much more
important than the childhood than the
parents because the peer group is is a
status game it's the first proper state
escape that they play and i guess that
need for that that profound sensitivity
to status i guess that mellows out a bit
as we get older yeah we can we that
that's a really interesting question uh
um so
we we we're definitely highly attuned to
that stuff in adolescence you know
acutely tuned and we definitely mellow
out um
i couldn't i'm sure there might be data
out there but i didn't come across any
data that looked at our need for status
across the lifespan um the reason i was
interested in that apart from
adolescence when
there's lots of work about how brain
change adolescence which maps onto the
status game idea
the reason i was interested is because
it seems to me that when we hit 60 70 we
do become a lot less interested in
status and i think possibly a lot
happier
as a result you know but i couldn't find
i was interested in in the science of
retirement like what happens that we
happier in retirement or not um but it's
really mixed it's really mixed
psychologically some people are happier
some people aren't and and a lot of it
depends on whether they chose to retire
or not but i couldn't find any clear
signal in in that but so so i don't know
is the answer to the question but i i
have a strong suspicion that our need
for status
kind of
is very high in our teens and twenties
um maybe kind of plateaus
i kind of hope it starts going down the
50s 60s 70s i don't really hope it does
because it's exhausting
i
i i wonder is the
is
it's
evolutionarily is the pursuit of status
like a sort of survival reproduction
type thing yeah it's completely
connected to violent reproduction
because it's um
in in the groups in which we evolved the
more status you you got yeah the the the
more food you got the better food you
got the safer your sleeping sites the
greater your choice of
access to your choice of mates um the
the the the better your children were
looked after so it's it's deeply deeply
implicated in survival and reproduction
basically the more status we got the
better able versus valve and reproduce
so that's why it's very basic heuristic
in the brain go for status yeah because
if you go for status everything else
gets better and that's why it's so
fundamental that's why it's such an
obsession because it is a it's a proxy
for survival reproduction nice so we've
got um
a maxim mill x in exxon who asks is
virtue signaling disingenuous
no virtue signaling everybody has virtue
signaling we all do virtual signaling we
all do success signaling we all do
dominant signaling you know when we
crossed with somebody you know so so no
it's not it's um i i think it's
something it's one of those things like
echo chambers so we've got a new like
fashionable phrase with something that's
always existed um you know echo chambers
we always
you know have group groups of
like-minded people who see the world in
similar ways and sort of clump together
with people who share our story of the
world and you know
we would there wouldn't be virtue
without virtue signaling because if you
don't signal it you don't get the
rewards of the virtue which is
people thinking you're a good person i
suppose even like saying please and
thank you is virtual signaling one point
and complaining about virtue signaling
is virtuous yeah
so it's a silly thing
yeah yeah yeah nice
uh we've got a question from ella louise
oh interesting um how would you
recommend dealing with someone who tries
to humiliate you in the workplace
without turning to gossip to make
yourself feel better specifically when
they're a manager who would therefore
have higher status than you do this is a
question that sounds like it's got some
yeah maybe she's gone yeah
wonder what ella's been going through
yes well that's really hard i mean you
know i i think i think if somebody is
humiliating you in the workplace that
that
you should never humiliate people you
know it's an awful thing to do and it's
also completely counterproductive
because when you humiliate people you
make an enemy and you don't you know you
don't want to go through life-making
enemies how do you deal with it
you know in my experience um people like
that um
that
if you find you're not getting on with
them what you generally find is that
other people don't like them either and
and if you kind of just tap that
a bit you'll find out that other people
don't like them
how do you deal with it without without
without gossiping is really hard because
gossip is is is another one of those
things that has a bad rep it's like a
social tool isn't it but it is it's
universal it's how societies function so
um you know
if you take that completely literally
you would say you can't tell anybody
about it ever which would you you're not
going to fix it the only way you can fix
it is by i mean so the way to fix it by
going up to that person and actually
sitting down with them and saying look
i'm fine
i'm finding it humiliating the way that
you're talking to me and if that doesn't
work
i i i would just you know
you'd ha you have to sort of report them
because you can't you can't go through
your work work you
your personal life being humiliated it's
it's it's it's it's an awful thing to be
put through there's no excuse for it i
don't think yeah yeah and i think like
sp speaking to that point that like
everyone wants to be the good guy in
their own life story if i as a manager
if i have one of my team members come to
me and say that my actions have made
them feel humiliated there is no way
that can make me feel like a good guy so
i'm like oh my god i need to change
something yes
any time i've been in that position that
has been what's happened uh yeah when
it's when i've been speaking to manager
or thing or things like that so
yeah i think often there's just a case
of open and honest communication yeah
and
we hope that people have sufficient like
goodwill and like niceness and stuff too
actually that's right yeah i think
that's exactly right is that sincerity
one of the um best things that boss ever
said to me
um was when i was when i was a features
editor so i was kind of had a management
position yeah he took me to one side and
he said keep the emotion out of it you
know you can talk to people and tell
people things are wrong
but you just get too emotional and when
you get emotional people get upset and i
thought it was such great advice like i
was so thankful that you told me that
and so i think when you are having those
difficult conversations at work
keep the emotion out of it so if you go
to that boss and say
you know when you treat me like this i
feel really humiliated but you don't
you're not angry you don't you don't
confront them in that way if you're calm
and not emotional about it i think it's
got much greater chance of having
success because then they're not feeling
like it's a dominance yeah based status
challenge yeah yeah absolutely um okay
vif tonnogenin asks can you trick
yourself into looking more positively at
yourself by implying online that you
have a lot
i guess like fronting online to feel
better about yourself
um
it's sorry can you say that again yeah
can you i i guess the question is
can you trick your brain into having a
higher self-esteem by kind of implying
on the internet that you have a lot a
lot i don't think it's a good idea yeah
i think that's a bad idea because
you've got to feel authentic i mean
there's the whole history of
the self-esteem movement um
in in america where
and it came out and it went all across
the west and much of the world really
and that was this idea i wrote about in
my book selfie
that if you if you do that if you if you
love yourself and boost yourself and
tell it to tell to tell everyone tell
the world you're amazing you'll just
become amazing and everybody will
believe it and it'll be fantastic and it
isn't true like that that's that's
that's that's a that's a one-way street
to narcissism you know so if if you if
you want to get status that's not
actually connected to anything real
that's what narcissists do they just say
i deserve high status and you will treat
me as high status and that is that and
people don't like those people yeah you
know like we're very attuned to overt
displays of status yeah
we don't like it at all yeah exactly
yeah i guess this whole like industry of
like signaling status without signaling
status yeah has sprung up because
no one's actually gonna tolerate me like
i am high-status exactly
okay just a bunch of rapid fire
questions that we always end up in the
podcast with um what advice would you
give to your younger self stop worrying
about everything
nice who's had the biggest influence on
your career the biggest i said the
biggest impact of my career would be my
agent and it's a boring answer but my
agent will yeah yeah i mean having a
good agent just choose a transformative
for your for michael has been my career
yeah
it's one tip for someone looking for
success just competence you know what
well is that that sincerest in the
competition i i think it's confidence
but it's also
under understanding that the i i think
one of the things that i i learned being
a features editor was
um you know when i came to work at arena
i wanted to bring all these great
writers from loaded and start using them
because they were great writers yeah but
they were just obnoxious right and and
you know so and so no matter how they
said they did really good work but they
just made my life miserable because they
were just so obnoxious um like one guy
submitted
an interview with anton deck with no
punctuation in it oh my gosh like what a
dick move like you're like so so so so
like it's it's and that taught me a
lesson was that you could be
unbelievably good at your job yeah but
if you're a dick
it doesn't matter so so yeah so be good
but yeah be a dick no yeah i guess like
competence warmth and seriously
seriously yeah yeah um what does the
first hour of your day look like so the
first year of my day i've got like a
secret twitter oh i've got a i've got a
twitter that i use to for to promote
things yeah and i've got a secret
twitter which is locked down in an
egghead
which is the people who i actually want
to read their tweets there's not many
people on it but i spend the first every
day like reading like my real like
my personal twitter with it with some
coffee yeah yeah um what uh material
item could you not live without i tell
you what one is i can't live without
yeah
there's a hot a hot chocolate maker
because i don't drink alcohol anymore
there's a there's a hot chocolate maker
there's a company called noops okay
k-n-o-o-p-s
they do unbelievable hot chocolate like
it will blow your mind okay and they
sell this hot chocolate machine that
makes these hot chocolates at home cost
about 80 quid i couldn't live without
that sick yeah yeah they're incredible
yeah they make the ah it's just
unbelievable i i didn't know how
chocolate machines existed yeah yeah it
it it
you put these like it
it's not like powder it's like um little
pellets of chocolate
and it heats them it heats the milk and
whisks it at once at the same time
unbelievable
love it um what books uh what book other
than your own would you recommend to
anyone
would i recommend to anyone
um so i really like this book um you
could do anything your with your life oh
our real moat by a guy called andrew
hankinson so he i really like andrew
he's um he's a very very creative
non-fiction writer so very experimental
and and so this book he managed to get
access to all round boat was his spree
killer um he managed to get access to
all his kind of personal documents and
he sort of recreated his life story just
using his kind of personal documents his
kind of psychiatric reports and all this
stuff so it's a really fabulous book so
i'd recommend that to anybody nice love
it um what quote or mantra do you live
by
oh that's a really good question
the quote or manchester i live by is you
could never expect a 100 life if you get
a 51 you've won
no day you can never expect a 100 day if
you get a 51 you've won charles
burkowski said that i think that's a
really good it's a good way to live your
life if you get a 51 you've won nice
yeah i love it and finally journey or
destination
journey every time nice love it well
thank you so much for coming on um links
to all of the books and your socials and
all the things will be in the video
description or in the show notes
wherever people are watching this guys
check out the book it's very good on
audiobook on audiobook um this looks
quite intimidating in real life but it's
on on audiobook i promise it's not and
it's it's generally very interesting so
thank you so much for coming on thanks
for having me ellie it's been a great
conversation thank you all righty all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye